all right
welcome to the first of my
readings of my 10 year old book
reason fulfilled by revelation the 1930s
christian philosophy debates
in france you notice that i'm listed on
the book
as editor and translator which means
that
much of the book is actually
translations
from the french of various important
pieces within the 1930s christian
philosophy debate
and i also provided at the very end a
very long
bibliography a chronological
bibliography that could be useful for
people
but i also wrote the introduction to it
which wound up being about 100 pages or
so and
today i'm going to read the first 10
pages
of the book which comprise the very
beginning of the introduction you could
call it the introduction to the
introduction
and then the two sections principles of
selection of documents
and debate or debates and if this this
goes
well you know we'll continue on plowing
through the book
and uh yeah i don't think anything needs
more to be said at this point this is
kind of an experiment on my part i'm not
quite sure how long it's going to take
me to read 10 pages but
after we get that done we can have some
you know q a
and discussion before i have to get to
the next
key thing of the day so with no further
ado
introduction in 1931
a set of extended and complex debates
began
in earnest within francophone
philosophical and theological circles
from their beginning they embroiled
numerous luminaries of the french
philosophical and theological scenes
ultimately provoking production and
publication of a substantial
and at moments brilliant body of
literature discussing debating
and widening the scope of the issues in
the pages of numerous francophone
journals
and reviews the issues raised provide
provided central topics motivating
contentious discussions in meetings
of the society frances de philosophy the
society detude philosophy
and the society scholarly contributions
made in other meetings and even
popularized presentations to the
interested
public three of the most important
interlocutors etienne jill
jacques martin and maurice blondell
brought out books amplifying their
respective positions in 1932 and 1933
and during those years and those
immediately following francophone
scholarship continually revisited the
key issues positions and figures
producing here's a quote an immense
literature which will not be easy to
command and that that is from
fairness steinbergen who took part in
the debates
as one long-standing participant and
commentator put it
a literature eventually spilling over
into english
italian german spanish portuguese and
latin
the debates the participants positions
and the issues they raised
and treated under the general rubric
christian philosophy have continued to
draw attention
and discussion providing a topic
periodically
motivating conference presentations
articles and books down to the
present day the reason for translating
the articles incorporated into this
volume here we go
is to make available for the first time
in english
translatable portions of what are
arguably the
most central previously untranslated
documents constituting the first phase
1931 of the debate and several of the
most salient and influential documents
from the wider discussions of the
debates
second 1932-33 and third
1933-36 phases
providing these translations has three
fuller motivations
first having these documents available
in english and compiled in a single
volume allows readers without french
fuller and more comprehensive access to
the debate's material contents
second this also allows the debate's
scope complexity and depth to come into
view
and thus hopefully to inform further
study and discussion of the debates and
their
issues third and more personally these
translations and introductions are
intended as a small contribution to the
history of philosophy
each motivation merits some additional
explanation as do the documents
selections these translations
aim to fill in for anglophone readers
several of the wide and often
unsuspected gaps in accessibility and
availability of the debate's
materials at the most basic level
simply making these texts available in
english allows readers without french to
now peruse
and study important documents that have
been for all practical purposes
terra incognita known to most only
through glosses bibliographical
references and translations of passages
jean joseph made hughes observation
about these debates is entirely correct
no analysis presentation or
interpretation can replace
reading the writings in which the key
personalities
of this philosophical dialogue express
themselves
exacerbating the problem many of these
documents published in various
francophone journals are readily
available only
in research libraries of well-equipped
major
universities and in more specialized
institutions
as i discovered in the course of my own
research researches and translations
there is
also no fully comprehensive bibliography
of the debates
and in intertextual references the
debates literature
assuming familiarity with a certain
intellectual
milieu on the part of its readership
often issues providing references to
many
of the documents constituting the debate
second
phase and i've got a little footnote
here that i'm going to read
one method i applied at the start of my
research aside from following up
available intertextual leads
was simply digging through the
university of notre dame's libraries
philosophy and theology stacks
exhaustively examining every relevant
journal from 1928 to 1940
for any discussions pertaining to
christian philosophy
intellectual spade work that turned up
many a hidden jewel
simply put this volume provides
anglophone readers
access to a much fuller range of
material hoping
hopefully opening up fields for further
scholarships extending to
reconsiderations of and dialogues with
present day discussions of christian
philosophy
and there's another footnote here that
i'm going to read because it
it really has um something to do with
with the the project so
footnote 6 four main fields of
contemporary scholarship are envisioned
as likely subjects for such
reconsiderations
and dialogue first those working
explicitly within the catholic
intellectual tradition can always
benefit from renewed contact with
portions of that tradition that may have
been neglected
second there is a long-standing and
growing body of protestant particularly
reformed protestants scholarship on the
issue of christian philosophy
with forums in philosophical and
theological journals the society of
christian philosophers and other more
denominational societies
third there is anglophone scholarship in
the field of continental philosophy
which can assuredly benefit by a more
comprehensive view of 20th century
french philosophy realizing for instance
that the recent
theological turn to phenomenology not
only represents nothing radically new
but also has intellectual roots in a
broader context of french philosophy
roots often excised in its
transplantation to anglophone soil
fourth there is the wider field of those
working in disciplines such as
philosophy of religion history of
religion and religious studies
so end of the footnote remedying these
gaps
in accessibility and availability of the
debate's materials also involves
promoting a more adequate understanding
and appreciation of the scope
complexity and depth of these debates
about christian philosophy
that has with several notable exceptions
unfortunately been lacking in anglophone
literature about the debates their
issues and their main protagonists to
francophone readers
the breadth of the debates is readily
apparent after only a modicum of digging
through the documents
at least with respect to the main
participants the differences in their
contributions criticisms responses
and positions and relations to each
other are not difficult
to discern admittedly
francophone's secondary literature
contemporary to the debates is not all
of equally high quality or value but it
at least possesses the merit of either
providing or presupposing a fairly
synoptic overview of the debates
the same cannot be said of anglophone
secondary literature in which the
debates and
have often been unduly truncated to a
jill some bregier
or less frequently a jillson fonstein
bergen debate
and i'm gonna read the footnote here as
well
contemporary examples of this trend are
the late joseph owens towards a
christian philosophy and leo sweeney's
christian philosophy greek medieval
contemporary
reflections even marilyn mccord adams
nuanced and insightful study history of
philosophy as a tutor of christian
philosophy mentions
only joseon and von steinbergen
frankly a significant portion of the
anglophone literature and even some
contemporary francophone literature is
markedly inferior philosophically in
comparison
with the better secondary literature
produced during the debates
and the cause of this is often that
these authors exhibit only superficial
or partial knowledge of the debates all
right back to the
the text there are understandable
reasons for this the problems with
anglophone literature
stemming from contingent historical
vicissitudes jill
and mariten lectured and taught in the
anglo-american world and they
participated in meetings of the american
catholic philosophical association
accordingly their works bearing on the
debate for example jillsone's the spirit
of medieval philosophy
maritans christian philosophy were long
ago
competently translated into english and
are commonly available and well known
also the case for breer's history of
philosophy
since the accounts of the 1931 society
francis de philosophy
meeting remained untranslated which is
understandable given the
society's policy of not permitting
translation of the discussions but only
of maine presentations frenchless
scholars
might not even suspect that rather than
merely the first two brahe
and joseon it includes the positions of
five major interlocutors
also maritime
the book length account of the 1933
society tom east meeting remains
untranslated at this point
as does blondel's the problem to the
philosophy catholic
previously untranslated and included in
this volume is the 1932
associated philosophique session
dedicated specifically to blondel's book
one article published by andrei de
lubach near the end of the debates has
previously been available in english
translation
and while that text provides overviews
of most of the debate's main positions
and interlocutors it does not appear to
have been widely studied by anglophone
scholars writing about christian
philosophy
in this context an unintended
but self-perpetuating dynamic prevalent
in anglophone scholarship and
translation developed
investments in the time and effort
required for translation of philosophers
typically depend on current
interest in those philosophers and on
shared scholarly assessments that their
works merit the time
and work of translation interest in
philosophers let alone evaluation of
their works however depends
significantly
on their work's availability and
accessibility this depends in turn
at least in part either on availability
of existing translations
or on assessments that the work is worth
the trouble of studying in the original
language
it is all too easy particularly for
debates more than seven
decades past to assume that if a text is
important
or valuable by now someone else would
have translated it
and it is likewise all too easy to to
draw the correlative inference that some
sense some texts from the christian
philosophy debates have not been
translated
they evidently contain nothing of
importance not already competently
summarized in the existing secondary
literature
aiding this inference is on the one hand
the earlier noted fact that the full
extent of the debate's literature is not
immediately apparent
even for a french reader let alone a
french less reader
and on the other hand the confirmation
of this inference by some of the sources
available in translation
marathons polemic against blondel in an
essay on christian philosophy continued
in his degrees of knowledge and science
and wisdom
jillson's deliberate near silence about
blondel in his works after the debate
and maurice nadel sells adoption of it
and is there a christian philosophy of
andre du marie's highly restrictive
interpretation of blondel's position
contributed just as much to obscuring
as to presenting the issues and
positions of the debates
accordingly the first goal making
previously untranslated contents
of the christian philosophy debates
available a goal only partly achieved by
this volume given the amount of yet
untranslated material
inevitably leads to the second goal
bringing the debate's
full scope into light in return
as complete and as comprehensive and
understanding as possible the positions
in the debates their mutual relations
and of the documents most
adequately embodying and articulating
them is required in order to inform
the selection of texts and the
interpretive processes
of translation my hope
is that availability of these documents
in english translation will allow
scholars to better
form their own reasoned judgments
on the debate's importance structure and
complexity and on the value of the full
range of participants
contributions on a more personal level
these translations were carried out and
are intended as a contribution to the
history of philosophy
simply put the debates represent an
important period
in 20th century french philosophy that
in my view
deserves to be made readily accessible
to french-less readers interested in the
history of philosophy
and more broadly in the history of ideas
the full list of interlocutors from 1931
to 1936
constitutes a veritable play of
francophone catholic as well as a few
reformed
philosophers and theologians christian
philosophy
was for a period of several years the
issue
of the day a case could also be made for
the literary and stylistic
value of some though assuredly not all
of the texts
all right so now we go into the next
section
principles of selection of the documents
the documents translated here represent
only portions not the entirety of the
debates but my hope
and claim is that they adequately
present some of its most essential
moments and most important positions
in order to keep this volume to a
manageable size several criteria for
inclusion were first applied to the
wealth of documents actually comprising
the debates
only documents that represent continue
and contribute to the discussion
to the greatest extent are included
namely those that
won articulated positions of central
importance in the debates
two contributed important and succinctly
expressible insights
three provided new critique of positions
in the debate or
four argued for compatibility between
seemingly irreconcilable positions in
the debate
three additional considerations then
figured into the choice of documents the
first was the sheer
length of certain texts which precluded
any hope of their
inclusion here several very important
and pertinent documents remain currently
untranslated because adding them to this
volume would greatly increase its size
and simply excerpting from them would
not do them
adequate justice these include books for
example jealous
la philo sophie critienne elea
contemporane
blondel's aforementioned the problem the
philosophy
catholic conference volumes for example
the society
philosophy
11 september including more than 150
pages of presentations discussion and
correspondence of major importance
and longer articles for example blaise
roemeier's
authur the problem of the philosophy
tien
the relative importance of the documents
and the authors gauged from the
perspective afforded
by 1930s francophone literature on the
debates was a second consideration
the authors and documents included here
are the ones most frequently discussed
not only by each other
but by the numerous authors and in the
many documents that
yet remain to be translated not being
included in this volume is
not an index of a lack of philosophical
value
for many pieces make interesting even
vital points about christian philosophy
not made elsewhere it is instead only a
consequence of the lesser
interest they drew from their
contemporaries in the case for example
of michelle surioz
1932 cascon philosophy catienne
the only specifically augustinian
contribution to the debate it is
highly unfortunate because his article
was of significant philosophical value
and extremely pertinent to the
developing debates
but it seems to have been almost
entirely ignored by the other
interlocutors
here's a footnote here the few
exceptions are brief mentions in fourth
and matt's presentations in the
philosophy
right the cecility tom east
presentations
given these exclusions a brief apologia
for my inclusion of four blonde l
contributions is in order
first as noted earlier one goal in
translating these documents
is to provide an english language
readership opportunities to study the
debates and their full scope and
complexity
this entails restoring as much as
possible several of the many voices
taking part in these ongoing dialogues a
few of these are admittedly
minor but not for that unimportant
others are
of major importance and if blondel seems
to be given inordinate space here
in comparison to jill some maritime and
marcel it is precisely
because his voice unanimously
acknowledged as central to the debates
by their french participants and
commentators
as well as contemporary foreign
observers fell mute
in the anglophone world by comparison to
these other major interlocutors
whose other works pertaining to
christian philosophy have long ago
been translated into english second
as with just one marathon who similarly
refined their position study of
blondel's text provided here
will reveal continual re-examination and
progressively fuller articulation of his
position
for adequate understanding of that
position each of the
translated documents is needed third
glancing over the bibliography provided
here will indicate that still more
blundellian works could have but
have not been included in these
translations
the third consideration has to do with
determining the starting point of the
debates
again consulting the bibliography
reveals that works pertaining
specifically to the topic of christian
flash
philosophy and to date the 1931 society
the the uh francis de philosophy session
and publication of brahir's article
as discussed in the historical
introduction the original debate
was long brewing why not why not then
include a mae forettes 1928
auteur de la nocion de la philosophica
tien or
antonin certillanges 1930 sir calcut
character the philosophy
the answer seems somewhat arbitrary but
the best and only one
i can produce is that like a war whose
reconnaissance posturing and sally's
begin before
any official declaration of hostilities
the christian philosophy debate should
be held to begin
officially with the very first
society francis de philosophy debate in
1931
this supplies a convenient historical
boundary mark nothing more but nothing
more is needed in this case since there
is near
unanimous agreement in the extant
literature
that the session marks the debate's
commencement
all right so now we have the the next
section
which will be the last portion that i'm
going to read and then we'll do a little
bit of discussion
debate or debates the
oft used term christian philosophy
debate
singular is somewhat misleading because
it easily lends the impression there is
only a single debate
one issue or topic being debated by two
opposed sides
the reality is much more complicated but
in compensation
richer and much more interesting to
study
in the first phase of the debates alone
three main explicitly developed
positions can be broadly delineated on
the two interrelated topics
of the possibility of christian
philosophy and the nature of christian
philosophy
position number one a rationalist
position represented by brahir and
branchfig
arguing that a philosophy cannot be
christian without thereby ceasing to be
philosophy
position number two a position developed
historically by jose
and doctrine doctrinally by mara 10
maintaining there were genuine christian
philosophies
particularly in the middle ages with the
implication
that faithful reappropriation of
medieval thought would be contemporary
christian philosophy
position three are a position
articulated by blondel
arguing that a christian philosophy must
be a contemporary philosophy of
insufficiency
open to be careful not to denature and
naturalize the supernatural
the march 1931 society france's
philosophy session
officially established the lines of
conflict between the first and second
and the second and third positions
brahir had already targeted blondel in
his early earlier piece referred to
in the society frances de philosophy
meeting and blondel responded
opening a genuine debate between the
first and third positions in his 1932
article
in the background yet another position
noted by jose and mara 10 in their
contributions and held by many
neo-scholastic tomists
a position mentioned but not explicitly
championed during the first and second
phases
of the debate denied the possibility of
christian philosophy but differed in its
reasons
from the rationalist position construing
philosophy as an activity of purely
natural reason
to which faith and revelation would
provide a purely
extrinsic supplement an explicitly
augustinian position critical of both
rationalism and neo-scholasticism
discussed in general terms by jill saul
and most explicitly developed by sorio
presented yet another position for
christian philosophy
from the very start then the christian
philosophy debate
comprised several different debates
all of them held together by the common
theme of christian philosophy's
possibility
and by implication its nature the
scope of the debates winded in the next
few years as more participants entered
them and as the debates were extended
into different philosophical and
theological
forums in his writings during 1932 and
1933
maritime continued his critical
engagements with both the rationalist
and blondel positions
julson left france to present his
gifford lectures soon published
as the spirit of medieval philosophy
blondel
published the problem in 1932
introducing further discussion by
transposing the christian philosophy
debate into a debate about
catholic philosophy as well in the same
year gabriel marcel articulated yet
another position
that reflected on and partially
reconciled the jill solmartin
and blondel positions but made
significant new
contributions of his own in essence
setting out
yet another catholic position in its own
right
of the host of articles discussing
christian philosophy that appeared in
french from 1932 to 1936
many explicitly took sides with the
major catholic interlocutors josol
marutin or blondel others for example
those included here by certian and
desolage
attempted to reconcile these various
positions
arguing they were complementary to each
other in addition
sertian is like marcel quite arguably
made some original contribution of his
own as did
atm born other articles argued against
the possibility of a christian
philosophy in a rigorous sense of the
term and
interestingly none of these were
authored by the rationalists who after
1931 made no effective responses
or further contributions to the debate
but by contemporary neo-scholastic
several of whom brought
phenomenological resources in to bolster
their positions
all of these articles and works those
translated here and the host of still
untranslated literature widened the
scope of the debates
yet several central questions
continually
anchored the interlocutors discourses is
christian philosophy possible what would
the nature of christian philosophy be
have there been any genuinely christian
philosophies
are there any now what would the
relationship of present christian
philosophy
to past christian philosophy be
against this background it would not be
entirely misleading to speak of a
christian philosophy debate perhaps
even so of a 1930s christian philosophy
debate in france
but only if the multiplicity in the
interwoven tissues of dialogue
disagreement critique and reconciliation
comprising debate would be duly
acknowledged
so that's that's all that i'm going to
read for today we'll we'll do some
additional
readings uh in the weeks and months
to come that's the first 10 pages
of the introduction to reason fulfilled
by
revelation the 1930s christian
philosophy debates in
in france and so it took me about half
an hour to to read that
so that gives me a good gauge for what
we can do so we've got we've got time
for questions
comments some interaction everybody's
saying hello so i'll say hello to
everybody
dammit albert says as someone that is
now learning german because
temporal studies are based on or many
trans untranslated german works i
appreciate this
initiative yeah there's there's a host
of literature
that's out there you know i mentioned
this vicious circle that takes place
right
so if something doesn't get translated
it's way too easy for people
who don't read the original language to
assume oh well it's not very important
if it hasn't been translated so i'm not
going to bother reading it
or asking for translations and it just
goes into kind of a
historical vacuum and that's that's what
happened with the christian philosophy
debates you know
um people in in the english speaking
sphere had
uh jose and martin's books they they
knew
vaguely you know for example joseph
owens mentions
blondel's uh the poe blem de la
philosophy catholic and then totally
mangles the little bit that he
he mentions because he already knows
that jill saw and maritime are the right
position
and didn't bother to do any any further
reading and this is a big
problem henry de lubeck's
overview i think got overlooked by quite
a few people because
henri dulubach is you know very
influenced by blondel
and was considered part of the nouvelle
theology that conservative catholics
don't like
and typically misrepresent so there's
there's a lot of people who
didn't with this debate don't know the
scope of the debates
and this also extends to all sorts of
other things you know this is a dynamic
that is quite universal i was just
talking with a friend of mine
a couple weeks ago about chinese
pure land buddhist texts and how few of
them are actually
translated into english and there's not
as much interest because
you know if you're really into it you
learn the chinese and then you you can
read them
japanese too pure land buddhism is
important there
and the ordinary joe on the street you
know
um going to services and
and chanting is probably not going to
engage in that translation work either
so you know a very important school of
buddhism
effectively gets misrepresented or left
out
and this is very common in you know uh
the anglophone the english speaker
scholarly world this this dynamic of
not um not seeing things translated and
so assuming that they're not important
and then not translating them
so all right um
damon says have not read but thinking
about camus addressed to the monks
dominican i don't know that
has it has any relevance here camus
is much later than than this
debate but who knows
dammit says remember to like the stream
to please the algorithm gods
mark asks how did the experience of
working on this book and form your
relationship to christianity so that's a
good question
i mean part of what attracted me back to
christianity
was the existence of a vast intellectual
tradition
that all too often gets left out by
people who like to keep things nice and
straightforward and simple and have all
their little boxes
which you know i mean blondel's point
about
christianity and philosophy is that
christianity blows the doors open if
it's if it's
genuine christianity not some you know
neo-scholastic thing or you know trad as
they call it now
or whatever what you know integralism or
any of those sort of things blondel by
the way is a critic of integralism
back in the 1910s um
those sorts of stultifying approaches to
to religion
oh we've got it all figured out you know
just shut up and you know
go to mass and do authority that's
that's undermined by realizing that
there is this very
vast and complex tradition of thinkers
who took these ideas seriously made them
parts of their lives
and then there could still be debate and
disagreement after that
right there was no one single stan pant
thomas is always right kind of thing
going on
within these these debates and it's
interesting um
two of the uh major
well actually yeah two two of the major
uh interlocutors in the debates are
converts
maritime and marcel right two of them
are people who came up within the french
academy encountering incredible
hostility
from the secularism of the third
republic blondel
and jill so and found ways to to work
within them
all right michael asked how would you
define the terms reason and revelation i
don't
if you if you followed me for a while
you know i'm not a definition guy i
think definitions are something that
happens at the end of work like plato
says
not at the beginning right so i don't i
don't begin with definitions of of
reason or revelation those are words
that are you know far
too um polysemic to
try to impose a strict definition on
them to begin with
um all right columbus says i'm
kind of interested to hear about
contributions outside of france and also
the contributions of non-catholic
philosophers
such as the aforementioned reformed
scholars so um
it's a francophone debate right so where
else do they speak
french belgium you know um there are
some
there and actually when when some of the
french religious orders were forced out
in the very early part of the century by
the third republic belgium was one of
the places that they
they went to um and there there were you
know
french was was a kind of lingua franca
uh
at the time there are um quite a few
people
involved in the discussions and the
debates
in other places italy spain
you know there's quite a bit going on
there a little bit in germany the
germans didn't get too
too involved there were some
english-speaking contributions the
american
catholic philosophical association it
was either in uh
i think i want to say 35 they took up
the issue
and they were talking about it and yeah
when it came to
um non-catholics who were by the
by by far the minority you know and
um this is mostly a catholic discussion
but the
reformed uh were in parts of france
and um in switzerland and the reason was
the the um town of mets
was taken in the franco-prussian war and
the university there
actually had uh
a theological faculty very little of
that in the rest of france
um reformed protestants were the main
group of protestants
in france but they were a very tiny
minority but they
they were involved and so you know i
mentioned uh suriyo
um atm born would be another one
interestingly there's going to be
another
spin-off debate happening in the late
40s
and going into the 50s and paul recore
will actually play a young polar core
will play a role
in that um and they will reference the
the original debates and and continue on
with that
there were also reform discussions of
christian philosophy happening
in dutch but they had very little to do
with this francophone debate so you know
dewey are
people like that that influence people
later on like alvin plantinga
alvin plantinga coming out of the dutch
reform tradition
in america right but
those those treatments were usually um
less
deep you could say when it came to to
this
interestingly as i pointed out the
rationalists you know
uh uh brayer and braunschweig brunswick
by the way
was the teacher of both blondel and jill
song
um they just you know brunchfig did
write
a thing later on a book that kind of
touched on it
but that's about it they they really
made no significant contributions
after the first couple years so
johan can you say something more about
how this book can be used in religious
studies
it depends on what you want to do with
it i mean if you if you're interested
in the notion of christian philosophy
well this
this book is part of that if you're not
interested in that
probably it doesn't have much of a role
right it depends on
religious studies is an incredibly vast
field
so it depends on on what kind of stuff
you're studying if you're also
interested in historical
work about christianity and specifically
catholicism in the 20th century then
this
this would probably be germaine as well
if if you're you know not focused on
that sort of thing
and focused on other things then maybe
it's it's not that big of an issue
except i can't think of one other thing
so there are also discussions and
debates about
you know is there really a a hindu
philosophy you know
uh is there a x philosophy right and so
some of the principles that are being
laid out by the different sides i
suppose
could inform that and it could even
extend to things outside of religious
studies
to um you know there was that great
debate that lucian
outlaw was involved in is there really
an africana philosophy
well how do you how do you make sense of
it it's a similar
problematic that has to be
worked on all right um
kenneth says thanks for this work and
your work on blondel uh you're very
welcome
um colomous so the rationalist just kind
of helped get the ball rolling and then
walked away
it's better to say that the rationalists
were just swamped
by they helped to get the ball rolling
and then they didn't have that much to
contribute
they they sort of you know uh
shot their their their blanks early on
in the debate and then
when they it was time for them to reload
they were just being like lapped
constantly i'm mixing some metaphors
there but
um they they just didn't have much to
to go on i mean brunchfig i think
has more interesting stuff to say than
uh
brejer does but i couldn't translate the
brunchfig
contribution to well i did translate i
couldn't put it into the book
because the society france says that
philosophy would not give me permission
to publish that part of the translation
so
mark says can you give us an appetizer
of what more is to come
tease the contents page yeah that was a
perfectly reasonable
idea so there's a couple contents pages
um but this is the
introduction part right there we go
hopefully it's focusing well enough um
it's weird to see it backwards and this
hopefully it's not backwards in what
you're seeing
so there's there's a lot to come there's
a this historical introduction
that runs from page 10 to page 39.
uh that includes general background of
the christian philosophy debates the
debates french context
historical development and phases of the
christian philosophy debate so i could
probably devote a reading to each of
those
and then i've got a thematic
introduction outlines of positions
articulated during the debates
the rationalists
jacques martin maurice blondell
gabriel marcel neo-scholastic thomas
opponents
domestic proponents and non-domestic
proponents
of christian philosophy and then we get
the actual
um we get the actual uh
translation so you know part one
uh the debates begin we've got emil is
there a christian philosophy
which was from the review physique it
did morale we have eighteen
the notion of christian philosophy from
the society francis de philosophy
we have maurice blondels does christian
philosophy exist
as philosophy which was a letter to the
appendix in the account of the meetings
and then maurice blondel's is there a
christian philosophy in the review de
mediphysique morale
part two the debates expand 1932-33 we
have gabriel marcel's
regarding the spirit of medieval
philosophy
in the nouvelle review de jun we have
atm borns on a christian philosophy that
would be philosophical
found in esprit a really great journal
of the time and then we have blondels
the problem of catholic philosophy
in etude philosophique which includes
comments by enrico costelli
jean devil vey henri guyer joseph
marshall and then some discussion
between blondel
jacques paliar and gaston bergere the
third part includes five more
translations antonin safety yajes on
christian philosophy from la vie antedex
uel
bruno de salaja is the problem of
christian philosophy also from that same
journal la vie en telexuel
fernand steinbergen the society thomas
second day of studies in the notion of
christian philosophy
of course in the review neo scholastic
philosophy
blondels for an integral philosophy also
in the review
neo scholastic philosophy and finally
leon noel's the notion of christian
philosophy
also in that same journal from a
phenomenological
point of view and then i provide a
chronological bibliography up
up to the you know 2011 when this was
published
uh and then there's an index and so the
whole thing is
but uh wow man this is a long book
actually
three uh 317 pages um
so yeah there we go
um let me see what else we've got
judah says just place my order for the
book can't wait that's great
jordan tahimi says oh man release an
audio book so i can't release an audio
book because this is from
an academic press you know press this is
a catholic university of america press
so they have the copyright right and
they
when you sign over copyright as an
academic publisher
you're giving them permissions to do
what they are going to do with it
so you know by the way people who want
to see like an audio book or a kindle
don't write to me write to catholic
university of america press and when i
say write to them i mean write to them
send them an email
send them a letter and say i want to see
this book
in in these formats because they don't
care what us
authors think or want um they barely pay
us
that's as it is um i actually got a
letter from them recently that
unless you earn more than a hundred
dollars in a year they're just going to
put it into a bank and pay you out when
they they do
a lot of people very confused about how
things work with
with academic publishing authors very
little power
the presses all the power so if you want
to see this in different formats
write to them you know and uh you know
be pushy
because that's the only way things
actually get done
all right mark says i really want to
read this i'm going to go
try soft soap the university library to
order a copy
yeah you know unfortunately catholic
university
of america press priced this thing at
around 75 bucks
and that's one reason it didn't sell an
awful lot of copies except to libraries
because
if something costs more than 50 bucks
most people won't order it
um and that's that's just the way it
goes you know and there's
you know nothing to do about that um but
yeah you can you can ask your library to
order it you can
you can do that too if you if you belong
to a local library
like i should actually ask the local
milwaukee library to
to order it that would be another copy
sold
all right uh by ringing his father
garage lagrange not featured
did i miss his name he is not featured
because he was an ignoramus when it came
to this whole
issue he he did contribute one piece but
remember those criteria like making a
significant contribution
getting other people's positions right
garagu lagrange
was somebody who condemned blondel and
admitted that he had not read
and not understood when he afterwards
when he had read blondel stuff
so no he is he is one of those people
a lot of contemporary uh uh conservative
catholics
love garagu lagrange but on this sort of
and his stuff on the spiritual life is
good on this stuff his stuff is garbage
so it's not worth incorporating um
yeah let's see what else we've got matt
moyers
that was fast he asked if we were
interested yesterday and got right to
business dr sather wastes no time well
that's that's because i'm in between
classes right now
so i i can actually afford to do that
colomous i keep thinking of the kyoto
school but my notion of either so vague
i can't think of a connection there is
no connection between the kyoto school
and this sort of stuff as far as i know
i've never seen anything um but you
could say that there is a similar
problem of
of translation i i think right
uh jordan yikes academics get screwed
yeah that's been going on for a long
time
we are in a long-standing crisis
when it comes to academic hiring when it
comes to academic compensation
and security and when it comes to
publication this is this is not news
this has been the case
my entire career after graduate school
um if you don't know when when you are
reading a journal article
uh it's not there is no compensation for
the person who wrote it
for a book like this royalties are maybe
2.5 percent uh and that's after you sell
a certain amount of copies
right so the academics are not making
out on academic books and and
quite frankly i i think that the way to
go nowadays
is probably self-publishing i mean
you can make a lot more money with that
judah if anyone cares there's one more
copy left that's 75
the others are 100 plus it varies it you
know
you go and check one day there's a whole
bunch you go and check another day
there's only one copy or no copies
you just check in every so often it's
the same thing with other books
um the dark one do i have any good
philosophy of science people i'm reading
popper but i want more
yeah popper's not really a good one
popper is a okay one
i don't do philosophy of science i had
to study a good bit of it back when i
was
taking my preliminary examinations but
it's not an area that i specialize in
so not really um
oh matt moyers thoughts on norris clark
i know he's deeply interested in blondel
and may have some
significance in the debates zero
significance on the debates
he was a young guy at the time but
norris clark is a very
interesting uh ptolemist interpreter
he is the guy who um really brought
out the neoplatonic uh side that's there
in
thomas you know very often we get this
sort of stupid history of philosophy
stuff as well you know there was plato
and aristotle and you know in you know
we had
augustine and he was a platonist and
then they were all platonous up until
they rediscovered aristotle then thomas
was
aristotle and christianity and that's
total [ __ ]
they had plenty of aristotle uh
available to them through seneca through
boethius
through cicero who the monks were
re-copying and stuff like that and then
when they got their hands on
aristotelian texts
it was not oh we're all jumping on
aristotle
thomas is a great synthesizer you know
who does he mention uh uh you know
you could say second to aristotle well
of course augustine right
he also mentions ann so he also mentions
you know like about
a couple hundred other other authors as
well including cicero and seneca
uh who he's he's reading um and
clark you know was was going against
so how that ties in with this you know
the the the sort of
doctrinaire interpreters of thomas who
we nowadays call neo-scholastics who by
the way would include garage lagrange
they they had taken thomas and they were
like looking at it through these narrow
you know blinders clark helped to blow
that all open
he he uh you know wrote some really cool
articles
how influenced by blondel he's not that
influenced by blondel he's influenced by
blondel
and by process philosophy and by you
know actually reading the texts and
you know whole bunch of other people but
i'm a fan of clark i think he's pretty
cool
uh mr noodle would you recommend that
people interested in philosophy get
their phd or just get a bachelor's and
move on there is no recommendation about
that
you got to look at the individual case
right it would be silly to offer like
well
everybody should do this or everybody
should do this it's it depends on a lot
of factors right
um mark smith did you get any feedback
from contemporary catholic scholars on
the book
any word on how your book was received
well that's an interesting question
so um i i did get you know there were
reviews of it and some of the reviews
were
um the reviews that were
much more negative very often weren't
connected to the book
and there was a prominent thomas thomas
scholar
whose graduate student wrote me and said
hey we reviewed your book
and i read the review and i was like wow
your review sucks
because you're complaining about xyz
and i addressed that on page four of the
introduction
so clearly you and your professor didn't
read the book
when you published this review and i
didn't hear from them after that
but i ran into that guy uh the the
professor at a conference and he just
like gave me the cold shoulder
there were you know quite a few positive
reviews i actually had one guy come up
to me at the american
catholic philosophical association and
he said
wow you could have just published that
historical introduction by itself it was
so good
you know so in depth um i've had other
people who've used my
my work so it's that's that's kind of
rewarding um the book has been cited uh
quite a few times which is
kind of nice um it did not drop
stillborn from the press like hume says
about his treatises but i didn't
set the world on fire either and and i
actually you know
again pricing i i lay a lot of the blame
at the feet of catholic university of
america press for pricing it too high if
it had been priced at 50 bucks
i'm sure it would have sold 10 times the
amount of copies that it has up until
this point
um pricing it so high that mostly only
libraries would purchase it kind of
put it out of a lot of people's hands
and i have no i have no idea whether
they ever want to do a soft cover
or audio version or anything because you
know it's been radio silence from them
basically since they told me to go out
and promote it and gave me
five free copies so
uh all right
let's see
byringen how they claim saint thomas is
all aristotelian failed to see how much
he's influenced by saint theonisus
pseudo-dionysus of course uh i'll never
know
and and dionysus is only one of many
many many
neoplatonic interlocutors that thomas
has
pseudo pseudo dionysus is mentioned less
than augustine
is probably mentioned maybe as much as
as anselm
there's there's a number of others as
well boethius who he's
he's bringing up but yeah it's you you
know
people have this kind of cookie-cutter
history of philosophy
that then they impose and they teach
this
and you know it's really a different
form of rationalism
neo-scholasticism um is really
rationalism just with supernatural
elements thrown in
and that's that's one of the things that
blown down and you'll saw
and others were pointing out in the
debates
um javier do you
discuss cardinal desiree mercier in your
book is not relevant to these debates
not relevant to these debates except for
i think one mentioned by blondel in uh
the pope them to the philosophy um it's
it's really
there's a lot of people who aren't
mentioned who you know
could have been mentioned but you know
these people focused on on
who they focused on um interestingly
enough
a lot of the german stuff that's
happening uh
you know because there are some
discussions about
these topics happening in german
philosophy and theology those are not
trickling into the the french debates
um the french are kind of concerned with
their their own stuff you could say
there was probably
more interaction with
some of the other countries right
all right uh oh columbus says they might
have done the thing where they skipped
the introduction i have a bad habit of
skipping translators introductions
because i want to read the content it
would be kind of weird for them to do
that given that the introduction
is over 100 pages long and they're
writing a review
of the book and um
you know they uh
they would have to have to have jumped
right into the translations i don't know
why they would do it and i know that i
know that this guy
is kind of a sloppy scholar anyway i've
read his other stuff
so um spinoza do you like any radical
socialist communist theologians i'm
interested in the intersection of
marxism and theology
but that's not really an area that i
work in um there was a lot of
like inter catholic marxist or christian
marxist
discussions and debate going on really
from the 40s into the 70s
um so you just google that and you'll
find all sorts of people
interestingly one person who
participated in that alistair mcintyre
you know because you know he was a
marxist back then
there were even novels where you would
have a
catholic character and a marxist
character a communist character
and they would you know they'd be at
loggerheads with each other
and then it would turn out that they're
both decent guys and
it's their hierarchies that are the real
jerks
the little world of don camillo is an
example of that
graham greene wrote a novel like that
called monsignor quixote
and a lot of that goes all the way back
to chesterton you know you think about
the flying in and the ball and the cross
those sort of novels uh are fitting into
that as well
uh jordan says g-jeck is a pretty good
christian marxist reading of gk
chesterton i'll just have to take your
word on that because i've probably read
enough gisek
um you know at this point that i i you
know
i reserve my time for for others
uh instead um colomous doesn't
he meaning mcintyre that book marxism
and christianity i don't know if he
wrote that
as a whole or if he was a contributor to
it
um byron are
the anti-thomas mostly following from
duns scotus no there
i don't know what you mean by auntie
thomas because there's a lot of people
who don't like thomas but they're
they're not all following from don
scotus um
jada uh i'll look i've talked about
g-jack many many times in
amas that's the the places to go on that
um
i first read g-jack about 25 years ago
so yeah i do have some interest but
i have an interest in many many people
and i
ration out my time according to the
payoff and i don't see much payoff
these days um all right so we got about
four more minutes before i gotta
hop on to the next thing any last
questions
issues um i'll do the next
um reading probably sometime next week
we'll probably continue
through the summer magnus sell this book
for complete atheist
you'd have to be silly to be you know
that sort of atheist so i'm not going to
try to sell it
mark says really looking forward to
hearing more yeah this is kind of fun
um and it's it's good to come back to
this i
you know the book is 10 years old so
it's probably about time for me to start
doing
i've done some more work on this these
topics
after that but i should probably return
to it and i
probably do all you know some some
videos about it
so it's time to get back to it you know
oftentimes when you finish a big project
you don't really want to work with that
stuff if you're kind of a
person like me who has a lot of
different interests
um byron and franciscans versus
dominicans who have the better
theologians
they're they're both eclipsed by the
benedictines what are you talking about
uh cme thoughts on the gospel of judas
it's just silliness
and that was actually the thing that
made me
see that bart airman had sort of like
lost it as
a scholar and i lost any any any real
respect for him
uh cola moves how much do you think
these debates affected later french
philosophy depends on which latter
french philosophy you're talking about
um in some cases considerably french
philosophy is much
wider than the narrow little bit that we
get that we call continental philosophy
over here
that's only sort of a little selection
of it
people like jean-luc mario know about it
because he actually wrote about the
topic
yeah um
kenneth uh gets auntie thomas are also
novella teologia
that's [ __ ] a lot of the nouvelle
theologia
people are actually tomists henri de
lubac for example
so whoever sold you that line sold you a
line of [ __ ] that you probably
should throw away
um again narrow blinders right cookie
cutter
history of philosophy all right so two
minutes left
any any other last thoughts that you
want me to engage with
spinoza says thomas are okay if they're
not edward fezer
there's a lot of there's a lot of jerky
thomas out there there's a lot of good
tallness out there the good thing about
thomas
is you know actually here's the hallmark
if somebody claims to be atomist see
where they actually are going back to
thomas aquinas because if they're not
going back to thomas aquinas and they're
citing garagula garage or edward phase
or somebody like that they're not really
a thomas they're a fazerian or
garagu lagrangian or pic or a
mauritanian right
you always got to go back to the
original text right
um
as are limited edition cookie cutter
blinders maybe there's a million of them
out there
you know uh there's a million ways to do
philosophy
and do the philosophy's history which is
important to doing philosophy there's a
million ways to do it badly
um and you've always got to go back to
the original thinkers and the texts that
by the way was what the neo nouvelle
taylor og
was doing it's also called resource a
return
to the sources and thomas is one of many
sources
but there were many christian thinkers
before thomas
and they're all worth checking out so
the issue of christian philosophy is
going to be
understood in part by going back to
those thinkers and even jill sohn does
that in the
spirit of medieval philosophy right
um
zachary okay this is a good one to end
on do you think the cobblestone set is
still worth getting or is there a better
overview
um i haven't seen a better overview i
mean cobblestone is not you know
uh the absolute authority on things but
he's at least reliable
um grayling has brought out a history of
philosophy recently that i looked at
and it's it's decent you know um
i i think you know you should you should
always be focusing on the primary texts
right so all right
well i'm going to sign off and we will
take this up again with the next section
which is pencil long since i've i've
looked at this
we'll go to the historical and do the
general background of the christian
philosophy debates that may answer some
questions
that people are raising here and um
yeah uh this will be let me answer one
other question
jordan tahimi did you read these
thinkers in the original french how the
hell would i do the translations if i
hadn't read them in the original french
all right i'm going to sign off on that
i'll see all of you later